foreign
has offered a seamless connectivity and
the Advent of smartphones and connected
devices worldwide has elevated the
gravitas at which the data is generated
every minute zettabytes of data endless
data leaks and server Farms billion
dollar Investments stakeholders CMOS
ctOS and CEOs everyone is dependent on
one detailed report that data scientist
delivers a wise decision backed by data
research and Analysis can yield
prospering results still on the contrary
one wrong marketing decision one
misinterpreter detail could be a good
recipe for a catastrophic financial
disaster for an organization that's the
pivotal role a data scientist plays in
any organization a data scientist
caliber to device algorithm to crunch
numbers and extract precious information
is invaluable this is one good reason
why data science is reported as a top it
profession in the current IT industry
and is projected to be on the top for a
good time welcome to Simply lens YouTube
channel today we will explain why you
should learn data science before we get
started take a moment to subscribe to us
and hit the Bell to get notified of our
content if you are watching this I'm
sure you are interested in data science
looking for a flexible and online
training program that better suits you
like a glove and helps you get ahead in
your career well your search ends here
simply learn is offering an online data
science bootcamp with Caltech in
collaboration with IBM here you will
maintain by real-time industry
professionals aligning your learnings to
the current industry standards to get a
better chance of planning your dream job
the course covers the most sought after
technical skills like exploratory data
analysis descriptive statistics
inferential statistics model building
and fine tuning supervised and
unsupervised learning and Sample
learning deep learning data
visualization and the course will help
you get Hands-On with important tools
like numpy pandas python R and sci-fi
what are you waiting for hurry up for
more details check the link in the
description box below IIT firms are
venturing into data science recognizing
its potential to open the doors to wide
spectrum of opportunities it enables
Enterprises to Monitor and Report
performance metrics to facilitate High
tuned and in post decision making
organizations can now analyze Trends to
make critical decisions to engage
clients better enhance company
performance boost productivity and
increase profitability the
organizational importance of data
science is increasing at a Relentless
Pace the global data science platforms
Market is poised to grow at a cagr of
16.43 more than any other industry
converging to it data science
facilitates it with its power to extract
information from larger volumes of data
information technology makes our life
easier by gathering and processing more
data quickly and efficiently to provide
results in minutes and hours unlike days
and weeks statistics and science have
become the answer to complex data data
science enables stepping and analyzing
massive amounts of untapped data from
many sources to leverage productivity
and profitability this is one good
reason why many Tech experiments find
data science to be the most interesting
job profiles apart from the IIT domain
data science has spread its roots into
other fields for instance the healthcare
sector is more inclined towards data
science and artificial intelligence to
diagnose and treat the most complicated
syndromes and robots to perform the most
tedious surgeries online stores and
shopping websites depends solely on data
science to manage the supply chain and
enhance the user experience by
recommending the right product data
science plays a pivotal role in
transportation and Logistics it provides
customized recommendations to best suit
customers comfort and manages unexpected
circumstances using Predictive Analytics
geographical experts weather reports and
many more employed data science to
predict seismic events Reservoir
Behavior climate interpretation voter
boys to enable navigation and more
construction companies are integrating
their process with data science to
enhance bloating constructing and
automating tasks to build better faster
and bigger projects in the most
efficient way possible in the
ever-evolving field of data science new
advancements and discoveries in research
accelerate rapidly you always get to
learn something new making everyday's
work exciting new data science skills
can be acquired endlessly giving your
Competitive Edge between knowledge and
expertise the salary of a data scientist
in India ranges from 15 to 25 lakhs per
annum and in the United States of
America the salaries range from 150 000
to 250 000 per annum depicting the
future of data science results in an
unmatched potential to settle in a
secure job role as the field expense
more jobs should become available as
more data scientists are needed for
analysis individuals wishing to pursue a
career in data science can look forward
to bright future with data science data
science has a huge scope across all
Industries the global market for data
science is expected to grow all the way
up to 230 billion dollars by early 2026
opening the gates for about 11 million
data scientists job roles another
important aspect of the future of data
Sciences artificial intelligence AI will
likely to be most powerful technology
data scientists will have to deal with
in the future to put it another way the
future of data science will align itself
to make it better in the long run to
become a data scientist the
Professionals in the organizations need
to have help the data literacy powerful
programming skills mathematics
statistics logic building skills strong
foundations in data cleaning and a
comfortable understanding of data
visualization and machine learning
algorithms handling all these are
nothing less than herding cats one scale
Gap could be the final nail in the
coffin if you are an aspiring data
scientist looking for online training
and certifications from prestigious
universities and in collaboration with
leading experts then search no more just
grab simply learns postgraduate program
in data science from Purdue University
in collaboration with IBM that should be
your right choice for more details use
the link given in the description box
below with that we have reached the end
of this video on why to learn data
science if you have any queries
regarding any of the topics covered in
this video or should you feel image
doubt on a point or two please feel free
to write us down in the comment section
below we would be happy to hear from you
till then stay safe and keep learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here